well welcome welcome to your mom's house
with Tom Segura Christina the ship's
to your house top dog something yet a
lot of people were really into his phone
call that's very funny
big feedback on their it was really good
it was it was uh imagine that he shat on
his comforter bedspread beds right and
got a little squirt on the bedspread you
know I listen to that call again yeah
and the part that really gets me is that
he wasn't he didn't intend on washing it
like he wouldn't have if he were living
alone that's the part if you go old
school and I mean episode I could even
tell you the episode but it's where my
dad sharded we were together yeah it was
the Oh
in Maine yeah in Maine and he shut five
feet too far I was good yes I didn't
make it I mean I was you know it was
just ugly
I hated to go
I just read the sign in the hotel yeah
and they had to go down the stairs and I
was squeezing the cheeks going down the
stairs yeah and then I went into one of
these places you know where you know
you're Russian but it's one of these
handicap stalls and it's an extra five
feet before you get to them
yeah and it's five feet too far five
feet too far that that whenever episode
whatever episode that was he shit
and he walked you know I was in the
bathroom in the hotel room we were
sharing hotel room Tommy you done in
there like I'm taking a shit what do you
what are you fucking asking me for like
he kept knocking he goes yeah I shit my
pants and I was laughing so hard and he
told me what happened and then we're
gonna go out we're gonna go out to a
movie or something and I go what are you
doing with those pants he's like put him
on my go you just shit in them well and
he goes I shit in the underwear oh and I
go by throw up isn't there probably some
on the pants goes just a little bit of
shed and I go
you can't fucking wherever so gross he
wanted to wear them out uh is so gross
yeah yeah there's a lot of I have a lot
of just shit clips from him and have his
oil in them already okay
and so then you need to do is is that
the end of the thing they were more they
would burn it they would take every day
everything everybody's shit together
yeah but I had multiple music it's like
about shitting in the shit and Vietnam
and they had to burn yeah their shit you
know it was like a horrifying right
right and then they would you would you
would burn it okay and okay and that's
why they call it being into shit right
did you guys like what you try to shit
in similar places like if I took a shit
here
would you come by the same area or you
just shit wherever you want to shit well
you would grab the bush you just find it
what you do you dig a hole with your
tránsito which is a military term for
shovel and remember what your in you had
a food you're eating in because you're
burning up so many calories the the size
of poops we had what about what a dog
does oh really
yeah cuz isn't the military we designed
them to block you up to like MREs now
they say are designed to be look as he
expired
once a day yeah why do I talk to halos
in yourself yeah
god I'm so stupid yeah uh yeah it's
horrible I got a bunch of those but um
he yeah just a little bit of shit it's
in there somewhere in that episode what
an animal he's an animal
what a faggot now I see all these bodies
you say top dog top dog like so old plan
what's here no you're a funny Oh this to
you my sister
Oh Oh call I don't know what this is
about even hello Tommy yeah hey buddy
how you doing hey what's up man ah just
chillin right now just chillin so good
gosh Ellen okay ba I've been talking a
little bit yeah yeah yeah everything's
going good you know good had been been
feeling pretty good you know a little
traveling at the Orlando Airport the
other day
the infamous Orlando Airport yeah I was
in there I had to catch a flight to
Memphis and had now the turtle and all
of a sudden I felt one coming on I
needed to needed to get in there and
take a dump pronto
so I go into one of those you know
terminal err men's rooms on yeah and
every stall is full except the handicap
stall again you so I so I charged in
there you know really came out strong
sat out dropped my load immediately and
then I looked in and there was only
enough toilet paper for one white and
this wasn't a single wife dump I'm
assuming this was a lease this is
probably a five five maybe six wiper
okay is it would you classify it as like
a glider or you know a blaster or
something like that or is it just yeah I
wasn't a blaster but it was um in
between a slider and a sloppy joe okay
hey will you turn the tv down in the
background yeah yeah okay and so oh yeah
so all of a sudden I look over they
normally you know as I've told you
before when you're traveling you got a
check to make sure there's pay I didn't
this is I had no choice in the matter
you didn't do your recently I'm actually
I couldn't super curious wreck site toy
forget this call of how he cleaned this
up I don't know how he cleaned this up
whether he took his socks off or away do
a recon because I had to go and there
was no other stalls available so you
know it was either there on the floor
okay so right so what I did was all of a
sudden I noticed that they have those
you know toilet papers covers and people
use the toilet seat cover totally sick I
never use them personally but you always
just sit on the seat yeah I did yeah we
sure just so I missed you too much
trouble to use those things yet and then
you use position them wrong end up
hitting them you know what I mean and
then you get bigger mess so I don't use
them but what I found out is use you can
take those Karimun little pieces and use
that it's totally paper look how proud
he is of himself that's got used that he
said it like a detective solving a case
right he's a brown lock right active I
don't know her at the house yeah hey hey
was there but I've done that too have
you ever used the that as a 12 paper the
toilet seat cover I have many many
occasions yeah because a lot of times
the ladies room there's no TP and I
don't know what is right in the ladies
room no TP because women have to wipe
every time
number two so right right right yeah
sometimes you're out a lot that makes
sense though yeah you can use that to
wipe hahahaha hey Dad what a genius
hey buddy how you doing good how are you
pretty good pretty good yeah yeah what's
uh what's going on well I'll just daddy
my new favorite lunch now is this
seafood Cobb salad fuck it no idea see
is that the the club he goes to oh I
don't know where this is the same place
every day he goes what yeah and the dual
Lane McDonald's I remember he was not a
fan of dueling that's old school yeah
yeah but he still loves McDonald's
coffee oh yeah
still oh yeah oh yeah I miss him oh my
gosh